hey on today's show we talked to a woman
whose husband sustained a traumatic
brain injury and she wants to know how
to rebuild community
we talk to an awesome teacher who is
drowning with struggling students
we talk to an introvert who wants to get
back out there
and he's struggling with how to do that
as covid goes away
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john dolone show thanks for
walking with us and hanging out
i'm so glad that you're here hope your
family's well i hope you're well
i hope you're back in school or i hope
you're never going back to school as
long as you live i hope you're eating
well and sleeping well and going for
walks and i hope it's spring where you
live
and if the tornadoes are coming i hope
that they miss you
we're so glad that you're here we're
going to talk about relationships middle
off we talk about everything on this
show
all of it right give us a shout if you
want to be on this show
i want you on the show i love to talk to
you we're getting calls and emails from
all over the planet and it's so rad
give us a shout at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291 or you can go to
johndaloni.com
you can fill out the form and then
kelly's going to make all the decisions
because she is the lord of the show
so and james i don't know james is like
i'm the producer
he's the producer i did not say that but
kelly is the lord it's awesome
all right so i hope everybody's doing
well hey real quick
we need to have like some family talk
here gentlemen
enough with the deep v's we're done
we're done
every time i see a guy with a dv it's
getting deeper and deeper and it used to
be
just like hey you just unbutton the top
button and then it was
like you had an undershirt it wasn't
weird and then it became like
no way dude we're gonna not wear an
undershirt and we're gonna go like three
buttons
and that gave me gas but it was fine but
now they sell them
they sell the dv it's not an undershirt
it's like no i intentionally went there
and i just wanted to
like go all the way down and here's the
thing guys
like we've seen tight jeans come back
and we now have mustaches back
to stop no deep v's like
dude we're about to go off the edge here
man just
i would rather limp biscuit clothes come
back than the deep v
to continue to make inroads into our
hearts and minds and souls
can we just stop like together together
we make a team that was the motto of my
woodland hills elementary school
where i grew up together we make a team
i think together we make
a stand against deep v's gentlemen let's
do it are we good we're good all right
cool
all right let's go to the phones let's
talk to
tamra northport i don't know why i just
paused it i don't know dude
i want to say like if it was tamara and
i knew it wasn't then it was tamra and i
got a friend named tamara i haven't
talked tournament i think i'm gonna call
her there's a lot going on up there but
we're gonna go to tamra in northport
tamra what's up
it's tamara or tamara but nobody ever
says
tamara so i appreciate that it's tamara
right
it is yeah i've got an awesome friend
named tamra she's brilliant she's a
wonderful
friend in abilene texas and i was like
i saw your name i thought i haven't
talked to tara in a long time i should
probably call her
and then i know you said there was the
other part of my brain that's like hey
you're in the middle of a radio show
maybe you should do that too
and so hey so hey
what's up what's up
um you know i just i thought i'd call in
and kind of throw you some situations
i'm in right now and
see what direction it goes um my husband
and i are both
okay so my husband and i are both 42 and
been married
18 years we have five kids and yes
we knew exactly what was causing it that
was fun
hey how many times have you gotten that
question you know that happens yes
idiot too many too many listen one time
i asked a buddy
hey you know how that happens right and
his answer was so over the top
to me i have never asked that question
again it's awesome yeah well then we had
twins and people were like
oh my gosh are they natural or are they
fertility like that's a really personal
question
hey listen yes everyone knows how babies
were made let's
never ask that question together we make
a team we're going to stop doing these
camera
and we're going to stop asking people
how babies are made let's just move on
all right so you got five tails and all
those things okay so that's where we're
at
married 18 years so seven and a half
years ago
my husband fell from a roof and he
sustained
severe injuries his left side was
totally crushed
um but what left him completely changed
forever was a traumatic
brain injury and so you know we've been
spending
seven and a half years just like what do
we do with this how do we embrace this
how do we follow this
and i he's a completely different person
he doesn't
look different that's that's the thing
like
why doesn't he have a scar because you
can't see it
so you know tell people give people an
example
um my oldest friend on planet earth is a
tbi survivor and it changed everything
100
start to finish um when some to a group
of people who don't know
um walk somebody through what living
with some of the tbi with a traumatic
brain injury
can be like and i know that like that
that that word that phrase
traumatic brain injury means a million
different things to a million people
walk somebody through the day to day
what that looks like how that's
different than it used to be
well you know to that's a book you know
and i'll probably write one someday
because
even when i was having babies and when i
had twins i mean somebody i found
somebody on the
on the planet that said i've been there
i've done that you're gonna be okay
and i've not ever had that conversation
with a person that has said
you know what i got your back we went
through it you guys are going to be okay
and so aside from my faith and my
absolute unconditional love for this man
and my community that we would not be
who we are because
most people relocate they divorce they
start over
because what it's done is it's it's
wiped the slate clean
in this person's body soul and spirit
and so
as they fight their way back you know
you have to
fight your way back and so as much as he
has changed
dr dalony i have changed and my children
have changed and so
it's it sucks if you look back on it and
you go man that is hell and then i can
like shift my perspective and go that
is such an opportunity like who we are
now you know
um but my question for you primarily
because this could go all sorts of
different directions
it's kind of a rabbit hole but i i don't
know how
to do what you asked me to do i don't
know how to communicate to people
you know how how different it is and i
don't know how to
help other people just live in our
normal accept it celebrate it
and you know the people i'm surrounded
by are not like
judgmental church-goers and nosy
neighbors and irritating family
they're my tribe there are people there
are they're the people that were there
we got married the ones that brought
casseroles when we had babies the ones
that have
you know been there and now seven years
later
we're like and we aren't who we
thought we were we kind of know who we
are now
um but everybody seems to be waiting for
us to just kind of
show up and be who we were yeah and i
mean i
i don't know my kids are awesome my baby
was not even two
when his daddy fell and our and now he's
nine we've got teenagers
kids are incredible not terribly
concerned about them
it's for whatever reason it's these
people
in my life that i don't know how to i
love my husband i fell in love with him
again like
i've been married twice to the same
person you know without the divorce
papers and all that [ __ ] you know
art stuff sorry um no that's exactly
what it is
that's exactly what it is yes it is and
and someone told me
like five years into it like you could
you were with him when he got hurt like
you're still with him
and i was like yeah you don't you don't
leave
but i really wanted to sometimes
but i don't now and so anyway so so
here's the thing
hit me with your best shot yes so
here's the here's the ugly nitty-gritty
of it
um let me just walk you through what
happened with my situation
and where things stand now okay
um my best friend on planet earth his
name is ryan
oldest friend we've been together since
we were zero and
the weekend after college he graduated
college with two degrees and
a friend of his ran a stop sign he was
hit by a truck
carrying porta-potties of all things for
the guy that we've made fun of each
other more than any other person on
planet earth
he got hit by a porta potty truck and um
has never been the same right and you
you know exactly what i'm talking about
here there's something about playing
catch
shoving each other in creeks and trying
to catch snakes and frogs and going to
baseball games and football games
together and then you transition to
changing his diaper and then you
transition to wiping him right
and that's another layer of that i
didn't know i had in me i didn't know he
had it in me right
and when your best friend on planet
earth is in a wheelchair
and then you're making jokes and people
are stopping you in a parking lot and
they're like how dare you it's like no
no i know you don't get it it looks like
we're being mean but we're not
right and you've been understanding yeah
yeah
um and so here's the thing
some of us dug in there and hung in and
then others
it changed it changed the game for them
yeah and i spent a season
so angry and hateful and what i realized
was
that wasn't changing their perspective
they had their own demons they were
working through
being a friend with ryan can sometimes
be really hard
right and sometimes it can be
challenging
and i always double back on it's worth
it right those friendships are worth it
they're super different now but they're
worth it
but i realized i was just poisoning
myself hoping that they would come
around
and i was the one that was drowning on
that deal they weren't
and so i had to construct a construct
a new normal for me and my relationship
with with ryan is totally different now
he was my confidant he was the guy that
sat me down and was like dude
stop messing around with your wife who
was my girlfriend for five years he's
like what are you doing
right and so he was that guy for me he's
not that guy because he's got a
different level of of cognition he's got
a little
a different level of process but he
still makes me laugh
he's still super insulting and he still
makes fun of me probably on a daily
basis right
he still makes me be like dude you can't
say that out loud right
that's still my that's still that he's
still there for me right pc
man yeah yeah absolutely not but all i
have to say is this
me waiting for other people to come
around was me choosing to
drown myself yeah and what i had to do
was
be grateful for the the friendships that
we had before
be grateful for those folks who were
interested in
this new shifting relationship and at
the same time here's the other part
that's that nobody tells you when you're
a great
like in grade school is even if
everything was
perfect a chunk of those friends would
have peeled off naturally
sure because they have kids and then
somebody turns into the weird little
league dad and then you turn into a cub
scout dad and then like
what's wrong with you video game dad you
suck right that just
happens and it turns into it turns out
that it happened
around the moment when your husband had
this traumatic brain injury and so it
all gets lumped together for you guys
here's the thing i'm gonna recommend
that you be open and honest and
receptive to whoever comes
and let the other nonsense go and it's
probably gonna be a season of mourning
some of those old friendships probably
absolutely
yeah no i've heard you talk about like
um grief
after a divorce like dude i did i did
the ceremonial things that made some
people really uncomfortable
but i lost him you lost him he's gone
but he's so capable
like he's absolutely capable he's
amazing and he can do so many things
but it's not like he's we don't have
diapers and we're just different right
he's different he's totally different
that's right yeah so what you had to do
like and you've heard me say this 20
times on the show you had to excavate
the 911 site and build a whole new tower
you couldn't just that analogy that's so
helpful you couldn't sit there and go
sweep up
all that glass and steel and twisted
metal and pipes and try to rebuild those
building you can't do it you got to
clear the whole deck and that also
includes everything in the periphery of
your life too
because your life changed right so oh
yeah your ride-or-die friends they may
not want to get on the motorcycle
anymore
and the quicker you can get to that's
cool it was fun
and move on and i know that's so hard
right because you want to say
hey if you all were my real friends you
would fill in the blank that is only
poisoning you
that can't be true they don't they just
don't know they don't know that's right
they don't know
another thing that's been really helpful
is ryan had a younger brother named
caleb
he still does and caleb taught us
here's what we got to do here's how you
do it and they were
really informative really direct i was
lucky that caleb was our friend for
years and years and years too
so i trusted him he trusted me and so we
we just cut through all the crap and
here's what here's what we need for some
help his mom nita was
like my second mom growing up and so she
cut through the crap and was able to
give me some instruction
it gave me firm footing to walk on so i
didn't have to tiptoe
right yeah and so some of that was me
receiving it but some of it was the
people closest to this his family
man they were direct it's got to be like
this or he's not getting in your car
right yeah right we've done some of that
there's no apologies there's no
weirdness i'm just going direct and then
i'm going about my day because i got
this awesome guy
i've got my awesome kids and i've got my
awesome life i hope that you my friends
will choose to be a part of it and if
you don't i love you and it's been such
a great ride
here's where y'all get off because we're
still going cool
and some of that becomes letting new
people that have been sitting on the
periphery that would probably be close
friends to you
let them i was almost gonna say let them
bloom because it's springtime here but
that sounded too cheesy even for me
true they move in like the people that
we've met after his accident
i i don't mind hanging out with them
because they invite me
they don't expect him to it's just
social limitations like it's totally
overwhelmed with more than three or four
people in a room yep so
you you guys want to come for dinner no
actually
you know we can't quit asking new
friends say hey you want to catch a
drink after work with me
and it's like they they get it you know
that's right i understand it so i think
you're right i know this
i just probably needed to hear it and i
want other people to hear this
because there's not a lot of help for
this a lot of people think he's a vet
because he's 42. he's not it's not
military
it's an accident but there's a lot of
people suffering with this and no one
has a resource it's bigger than tbi
it happens with divorces right like it
does
what do we do now right or when somebody
emerges like they come out in a friend
group and they're like hey i've never
told anybody this but i was abused when
i was 11 by this uncle and here we are
and then everyone freezes and they don't
know what to do and
some people double down and can lean
into that discomfort
and some people can double down and they
don't know how to lean into discomfort
and they get really weird and they say
awkward weird mean dumb things but they
don't mean it because they're just
trying
and then other people fade out and for
whatever reason
i'm going to assume they've got their
own trauma their own demon their own
things going on
i'm not going to judge them i'm not
going to blame them because that is
energy i'm wasting
and they don't get that if they want to
step out awesome if somebody wants to
lean in
and say something i'll be like hey dude
we don't say that around me and my
friends
cool and we're moving on right yeah and
then we move on yeah and so
i i it happens with all types of trauma
all over the place and what i want to
encourage people
that are listening i love that your
heart is you want to learn but also want
to be a resource for other people
yeah life is full of super weird awkward
hard ugly messy gross terrible things
you can never go wrong by leaning and
saying
hey what's the right way to say this you
can never go wrong by leaning and saying
it looks like things are really hard
what's a way i could help what we want
to do is take our one tool that we have
in our bag
which happens to be a hammer or a
screwdriver and just start whacking
everything with it hoping it will help
right
instead of saying us feel better it does
it does feel better to help someone and
it's
i do have a group of friends that have
been like they say about
job's friends where they some just sat
with him that's it
in his grief he didn't say anything i
have
those friends i have those people and
and and that is
priceless and i want to see that i want
to tell you this tamara
my you are a virtuous extraordinary
human
for saying come hell or high water i'm
i'm chained to this dude we're going to
figure it out
i want to tell you if if if if when you
sit down to write that book i'd be
stunned if you don't
backtrack reverse engineer what happened
and those people that just were willing
to come sit with a glass of wine and
just be there
if that doesn't become the foundation by
which you were able to anchor in and
love this guy and have to re-date and
re-learn a guy that looked an awful lot
like the old guy right
yep it smelled a little awful like the
old guy but he says weird crap which
what are you doing
right yeah yeah he likes likes goldfish
and
cats yes that was not the guy listen
listen tamara you gotta draw the line of
cats enough
well i know that they are outdoor at
least thanks good for you
i'm glad to see you're not getting i'm
gonna write the book i'm gonna do it
someday
and i just have to i just have to let my
light shine because it's
just about me if i make it to the end of
every day and i collapse in bed because
i kept my tiny little world
together that's not enough for me man
yeah it's about
here's where you are you're on the back
end which is
stage is it six you're finding meaning
what's the purpose of this
right yes where can we begin to turn
some light some candles and turn some
flood lights on
in other dark parts of the world right
and that's where you are tamara
your heart is is is gold man and i'm so
glad you're
you're out there having that
conversation having that communication
when there's a tragedy right and when
there is ugliness and when there is
heartbreak when there's brokenness
we often look on that isolated situation
how is that person's wife how's that
person's kids how's up that person's
job and we forget the periphery those
things
are like have concentric circles that
just come out from them and out and out
and out and that pain spreads
and so anybody listening if you know
somebody who's hurting if he's who's
been hurt
and it's weird and it's awkward lean
into the weird and awkward and say the
words
this is weird and awkward i don't know
what to do but i want to be here how can
i serve you
how can i just show up you can hardly
ever go wrong with a bag of cheetos in a
glass of wine
almost never unless they're recovering
from alcohol uh
recovering alcoholic and then don't
bring wine because then you're an idiot
right but you can still show up with
cheetos
or a box of little debbies or if they're
keto i don't know they
show up with a bag of meat or so i don't
know but showing up with food and
showing up with just your presents and
saying hey i'm just going to sit down
and watch seinfeld and then i'm going to
head out
showing up and showing up asking
somebody not
can i come do the thing i want to do to
help you but
how can i be a resource for you tamara
your light is bright and
i'm so grateful that my kids are growing
up in a world where you
exist and you're about healing
other people through your own pain and
trauma good for you and thanks for
setting an example for your kids on what
a relationship looks like what
sickness and health actually looks like
man that's inspiring it's awesome
all right let's go to uh admin amanda in
atlanta what's up amanda how are you
doing
hey john i'm good how are you today just
rocking onto the break of dawn yo
how can i help i gotta tell you first i
am a
ride-or-die tribe member i have listened
to every episode
but me and your mom are basically like
best friends hey she actually wrote this
morning she's like hey john your show
kind of sucks i'm out
so it's just like it's just like you
like last six or seven that's gonna be
it man so
yeah well i'll take it so um
what's going on yeah yes i'm a school
teacher
and i've been march tired since november
well i used to teach school too so i got
you know that
yes for those of you who know what march
tired is it's when you wake up every day
and think
i'm pretty much dead and i gotta go to
work and be there at 6 20 so that i can
do tutoring so then i can
do hauled pass duties so then i can
actually teach my class and then grade
the papers and call the mean parents
back
and listen to stupid administrators and
then go home and repeat
oh i'm sorry no then go do bus duty and
then go grade all the papers and then
it's 7
30 and i call whoever i love at home and
say i'm not coming home because i hate
my life and then i'm going to repeat
that's the march okay so go ahead go
ahead amanda
okay so i've heard you talk to other
teachers about how to offload your
bricks and all that kind of stuff my
question
is a little different i think um i like
to tell people
we can do a lot in march and april
because we know june and july is coming
right you know that
the natural rhythm of offloading as a
season
is right around the corner you know
we've got spring break coming and then
graduation and then
and and then summer and but but the
problem is
the the hope of of that break isn't
there
because we're in this this coveted
season and so you know
there's there's the goal line keeps
moving you know first it was two weeks
then it was six weeks then it was
the election somehow was going to make
it all better and then once we get past
flu season you know then it'll all die
back down
and now we're past flu season and now
there's this vaccine but wait a minute
it's not available for kids yet and so
it's like the goal post that that gives
us hope that this is going to be over
soon
keeps moving and we're seeing i mean
i'm high school so we're seeing like
tragedy after i mean
um you know kids just dropping out and i
feel like
i'm not trying to belittle by any means
the nursing profession but i feel like
i'm losing patient after patient because
you lay yourself out there for these
kids you're
you're you're accommodating you're
you're pushing deadlines you're giving
them retry after retry your
you know accommodations this and that
and the other and then they still go
no i'm glad i'll see y'all next year you
know or i'm out i'm going to do
something different
yeah um for me i'm a career and
technical educator so i teach business
and finance and
and how to get a job and communication
and so i feel like my classes are
are giving some kind of hope to the kids
because they can walk out the door and
go get a job and do
something right now but i have you know
i feel a little bit of this my my
faculty members say a little bit of this
and i just don't know what to do like
you're burnt out yeah well and like ken
coleman says
i don't feel like it's it's built it's
built up no there's
nowhere to put it because there's no end
in sight and even our
high achieving kids are are losing faith
in themselves
because you know our ap kids our high
achievers
they're getting ready for college well i
don't want to go to college because it's
all virtual now that's
that's not what i signed up for yep yeah
and so
now they're not even showing up and so i
mean
i just don't know what to do so um
kelly told me this call was coming and i
actually um
i've got a there's a relatively new book
out
um and it's called
burnout the secret to unlocking the
stress cycle by emily nagoski and she's
a
um women and her sister wrote it too
with her emily nagusky
uh and amelia but she's a health
educator and
she paints burnout in a picture that i
haven't heard of painted before
and it was this idea of it's three parts
emotional exhaustion this
this fatigue for caring for everybody
for too long
and then this depersonalization like i'm
just out i don't have any more empathy
or care or compassion left in my body
and then this was the the big one this
decreased sense of accomplishment this
futility
it doesn't matter what i'm doing they're
just gonna drop out right so here's the
challenge with that
some of that is real and some of it's
not
and it begins to paint like when you go
looking for um dragons in the clouds
you're always going to find them
you're always going to be able to find a
dragon a cloud whether it's actually
there or not
the more you go looking for dragons more
you're going to find dragons and
it that begins to loop because then you
get more and more disconnected it just
becomes futile which then you get more
emotionally exhausted and it just spins
on itself right
so here's a broader question
what what are other things you like
doing besides teaching
and i'm going to loop all the way back
around your students i'll get there but
what do you like doing besides teaching
is that rhetorical are you asking no
that's a straight up question oh
um i love going to the gym okay um just
exercising usually
are you a crossfitter please say yes
okay sweet awesome um so you care about
your joints and things like that good
for you
okay i try yeah there you go so you like
going to the gym
what are parts of okay forget the
outcomes by the way we'll just cut to it
you have tied your heart and soul to the
outcome here
and one of the the the challenges of
teaching
is i think is they put these
short-sighted metrics
on the relationship between the teacher
and their students
can they bubble in the right 13 answers
on this 14 answer test
this quiz that says they can x y and z
when it comes to chemistry
or industrial tech or fill in the blank
whatever
um whatever subject we're talking about
in my estimation that demeans and
belittles and reduces
the relationship between a teacher and a
student
between care and love and wonder with a
subject
to this can you get to this stage so i
can put you in this track to get you to
this room so you can get to that thing
and we've we've just sucked the soul out
of education we've made it this big roi
it's it's nonsense what we've done to it
and so
stripping all the outcomes away what do
you love about teaching why are you even
doing this job
you clearly care about those kids why
are you doing this
yeah i mean for me in my in my content
area it's it's
listening to them open their uh first
bank account or
helping them fill out their application
for their first job or
hearing the shenanigans about why they
got fired from their first job and how
can we fix that
you can actually be employed later like
i know that what i'm teaching
is gonna help them in their lifetime
regardless of what they plan to do
yeah you know and it's hard because on
one hand we hear a voice going
they're kids they need boundaries they
need to be held accountable no matter
what i know we can do it i know
they can do it and then you have this
whole other voice going
but it's a pandemic give them a break
right and and
intellectually anybody who's looking at
this from the outside
knows there's going to be a decade more
of
fallout from this last 18 months i mean
it's just
going to be you want to create if you
wanted to create
a way to torture a generation of
children
besides murdering their parents it would
be to lock them in a room and have them
stare at a screen for a calendar year
with no
human reason human interaction yeah
we've done it and we're going to live
with it for years and years and years
i'm saying the wrong thing i'm saying
there's going to be fallout for years
and years and years from this they will
remain you know and
having to retrain students how to do
school again that's right
how did you know you communicate with
one another how to sit there and be be
connected yes it's going to be hard it's
going to be hard
here's the thing though when you burnt
out and you're fried
what you start doing is looking for the
next dragon and the next dragon and the
next dragon and what you're doing now is
you're taking on the pain
and future frustration of kids
experiences a decade from now and you're
dragging that pain in the future that
may or may not exist and you are
setting it in your soul right now does
that make sense
and you're carrying whether they're
going to be able to get a job tomorrow
and what they're going to do at the end
of this thing and what's july going to
look like we've been coming back in the
fall
you've got all these things down the
road that because you're exhausted and
because you are
completely burnt out you have no empathy
or care left and dude i'm with you
i'm exhausted right um and because you
feel like a cog in a feudal machine
okay cool let's just throw it online
because that's the same right
the the natural thing you start doing is
running on a treadmill and just trying
to grab
future pain and future pain and future
pain and grab it and pull it and drag it
and so here's the thing you've got to do
you've got to back
way the heck up forget about the bricks
you got to back up and say i've got to
be okay so that i can head back into
this
because what you just told me is i love
interacting with these students
i love hearing about what they want to
do when they fell on their face i'm
there to
either laugh at them when they're trying
to crawl up or i help pick them up and
dust them off
and are both of them right and i love it
when they get their first job i love
it when they have a place to go after
they get fired from their second job
right
that's who you are man you can't fully
be
that when you're carrying future pain a
decade down the road that doesn't exist
yet
and the only way to not go down that
road and i'm
talking as somebody who has been there i
had to leave a university and take a
break because i kept doing that
these kids are going to be this is going
to be the future of this is going to be
if you guys
i got lost in tomorrow and i was unable
to
be effective in my today and what
happened was i burned everyone out
around me i stopped doing the things
that i loved because i was too busy
trying to
prevent the things that were gonna
happen down the road right and so
dr znagosky one of the things they that
here's the three things they say
and i love the way they say it because
they're writing two women in this book
by the way it's great for men too but
they're writing to women we'll put links
to the show notes here
they they say rest is resistance
for a professional woman who's trying to
help other people
this idea that i have to unplug and take
a break
especially as a teacher i cannot chain
the outcomes of young people
to my identity to my day-to-day
functioning or you'll drown
right the second one is how often
have you stopped going to the gym are
you still getting there oh no i'm going
every four days a week
good okay so the another big one is you
got to move your body
movement is resistant so good for you
is there a way that that has become
weightlifting has become an addiction
meaning is it time to go just for walks
is it time to pick up running do
something else that's going to stretch
your body and challenge you in new ways
that are going to also be able to help
decompress
and get the same cardiovascular and
physical and structural benefits
i've been in that space before but i
don't think i'm there now okay all right
so there's been times when i have to go
to the gym not i get to go to the gym
oh yeah for sure okay um and then
finally
you circling back and remembering why
you're doing what you're doing and what
you love about it
and here's a cool benefit my wife is
she's a she's a coach she works with
teachers and she's for years she's been
a
professor who worked with teachers and
pre-service teachers
and now she works with teachers who are
burned out and fried and cooked and one
of the things she always challenges them
to say what are the parts of teaching
that you love
and how can you do more of that what are
the parts of teaching that you hate
and how can you do less of that what do
you think
give me one of each what's something you
love that you can do more of
just honestly i just miss the
conversations with the kids i mean my
contents go
every day and i miss them when they're
not
there you know and they're not there and
i can't make i
i have a student i haven't seen in three
weeks but she hasn't withdrawn yet it's
like
i worry about them when they're gone do
they
have a daily journal that they write
that you read and
write back to them back and forth to one
another
no okay so starting monday it's going to
be a small writing prompt that you're
going to give them and say i want to
know
three things like how you're doing what
are you excited about and what are you
terrified about and that's a way that
you can engage
them whether they're in class they're
out of class they're going to keep
coming back to this thing especially
because you're going to respond to each
and every one of those
and it's going to be a little more time
but it's the thing that you love
sure you love hearing their stories
that's what you love
what's something you hate about all this
grading paper there you go so here's the
thing
i'm giving you on behalf of the students
and teachers of america i'm giving you a
pass
give less work we're all about the
psychological stuff at this point
especially with what you're doing right
you're preparing people's hearts and
minds for the workforce
and so yeah figure out a way to give
less work
no student has ever been said that the
teacher came in is like you know what
we're not doing
papers anymore we're gonna do this right
that's true
and so find the things that you love do
more of them
create con average news for conversation
i loved
the my wife actually taught me that
exercise she did it with her students
and i started with my graduate students
and it ended up being magic how's today
what are you grateful for where things
are going awesome and what scares the
crappy about tomorrow
in reading those in writing i got to
learn deeper about my students got to
learn more and shape my class in a
pretty profound way
but also i'm like you i just love
hearing people's stories i don't care if
you're a plumber or
or fancy pants i like hearing stories so
i'm going to set that up
and i like you i hate grading papers so
i'm going to only give one paper a
semester because i hate grain papers
right
i'm gonna i'm begged to hire i've begged
them to let me hire a graduate assistant
but they won't let me do it yeah they'll
never let you do that another high
school teacher
hey so let me let me say this okay let
me end this with this
you cannot solve a pandemic's worth
of psychological issues in your students
it's too big
if you're a nurse if you're a teacher if
you're an hr representative
if you are fill in the blank you cannot
hold the weight
the psychological the physical the
emotional the spiritual weight of the
people in your presence that you're
responsible for
in this case you cannot solve
the current the soon to be and way in
the future psychological challenges of
the pandemic with these young people you
can't hold all that
what you can do is love everybody in
your circle
really well right now and that starts
with you
being well and i love what nagatsuki's
sisters say
wellness is not a state of being it's an
action it's a thing you do
right it is resting it is moving your
body it is remembering
why you're doing what you're doing and
what you're doing and how you're doing
it and how can i maximize the things
that i love and how can i
minimize the things that i hate and then
how can i hose my boots off when i get
home
go inside the house be with the people i
love and then go to bed
right and begin that process of i can't
fix it i can't fix it all it's not all
weighing on me it's not all weighing on
me
and then you start aiming back into
sleep
right um check out this book um we'll
link to it in the show notes burn out
the secret to unlocking the stress cycle
with nagaski sisters it's incredible
it's a good read
um and thank you so much amanda for your
heart
who you are as a teacher who you are as
a human being
and what you're trying to do and i want
you to hear me say
you've been caring for these students
for 18 months
you've been caring for these students
for a long long time
now it's time to stop stop stop keep
caring for them
care for them today and caring for them
today starts with you caring for you
you caring for you you getting a gang of
people that are in your community that
you love
and that you all walk through this thing
together and then when you feel yourself
starting to
to stress about what's going to happen
10 years from now or 5 years from now or
this time next year we're gonna
just stop and say not my circus i can't
do anything about
what's gonna happen ten years from now i
can only take care of me right now i can
only love my students
right now bring yourself back bring
yourself back you're gonna practice this
over and over
you're gonna practice it i just hit the
microphone sorry you're gonna practice
it over and over and over you're gonna
get better and better at it thank you so
much for your heart
all right let's um let's see here dude
let's take one more call let's go to
alex in los angeles california what's up
alex how can i help
what's up dr john how are you i'm good
brother how are you man
i'm living the dream that's very cool
man i'm grabbing a drink of water here
my
my voice is going away so what's up dude
how can i help
so i had to write this down because i'm
like super addd
welcome to the party brother me too oh
yeah it's
a joy so what's up man
i put down uh basically so over the
years i have become more and more of an
introvert and i don't know if it's like
who i
am and just to be okay with it or if
it's something i'm
doing as like a self-preservation tool
what do you think it's
i bounce back and forth because there i
find myself wanting to go out with
people and hang out and do things and i
also find myself like i'd rather go home
and just sit with my dog
so do they have to be mutually exclusive
can you be doing both
well a lot of times it's because i go
out like with my friends at church when
i do
go out so i can't really bring my puppy
to church
no so what i'm saying is is it mutually
exclusive can you
becoming a little more introverted as
you get older and wiser and
tired or more exhausted and
you're also choosing to do different
things with your life withdrawing a
little bit
just because it's easier can you be
doing both of those things
i i'd say that's a possibility um so
what is it about this stuff that's
that's making you
uncomfortable like why the call
because like i found myself i want to
create a community uh with people
especially with this past year who's
like really
kind of reinforced it with me yeah and
getting people together and just loving
everyone despite our
differences on whatever the case may be
and but
it's like sometimes it's like okay you
guys gonna be a community and i'm gonna
go home and not be a part of it anymore
go to bed that's right i'm gonna talk
about it and then i'm gonna go to sleep
that's right i'm a i'm a instagram
social justice warrior right we're gonna
all get together and party and we're all
gonna have
our differences in good night all right
exactly
hey i've i've got a very similar
predisposition alex
um so anytime somebody tells me they
want to develop a community
with an outcome attached to it my first
thought is that community is probably
going to fail
okay if somebody tells me i want to
develop a community because i want to
get out there
i want to meet new people i want the
experience of hanging out i know that
it's going to
help me it's going to help me be well
it's going to help me
in all sorts of physical ways and
mental ways and physiological ways
if somebody tells me that awesome it's
gonna have some legs on it
if somebody says i wanna get a group of
people together because we're gonna
man that's probably gonna run out of gas
it'll either run out of gas 30 years
from now when you
quit the group or fall down dead or it's
just going to run out of gas because
you're going to be propping it up
because
it's outcome based right yeah
so i would rather you say i just want to
get a group of people because
i like being with them here's a here's a
rule i had
to make for myself i love love
love love hanging out with people it's
my favorite things in the world to do
and i'm an introvert i like i
i have i like to withdraw when i get
exhausted i would draw i like going home
and just sitting with my kids and the
chickens and being out on the moon right
so i have a rule that if there's
something going on that i know i would
love to do
and my first thought is i just want to
go home and go to bed
i have to go so if i'm leaving work and
somebody texts and says hey we're
getting the fights tomorrow
um are you coming and my first thought
is dude i just want to go to bed
my rule is i gotta go because i know
it's the right thing for me
i've never gone to the fights with good
friends that i love and
love being around or gone to some wacky
pool hall to watch the fights and it's
like
this thing may go down at any moment
i've never done that and regretted it
not one time
i have gone home and gone to bed i don't
necessarily regret it but i miss those
that community right
and for me if you're like me alex if i
do it once
and i'll do it again i'll do it again
suddenly i'll look up and it'll be a
month and i haven't hung out with
anybody
yeah is that is that you oh yeah
that's been part of the challenge is
getting back into society because i went
through a really hard break up and
there you go i completely withdrew from
everybody and everything and then
when i picked my head up everyone was
kind of dispersed and gone
there you go so here's what i want to
challenge you with
we don't talk use this word very often
with relationships because it sounds
gross
but it is what it is and that's where
we're at and that's the word i'm going
to use
as as the world opens back up in these
wonky
fits and starts and opens and shuts and
all that stuff as it does that
as it's gonna do and friends who have
scattered and found new friends and i
talked to somebody this morning on the
radio that just went got married
i mean people have just done things
during this season
right yeah as it comes back together
i want you to keep this word in your
head i'm gonna practice
friendship again i'm going to practice
i'm going to stumble through this i'm
going to fail i'm going to be awkward
i'm going to be weird i'm going to get a
group of people together and as soon as
they all show up i'm going to think
i don't want to be here i want to be at
home but i'm going to stay
i'm gonna i'm gonna make jokes i'm gonna
laugh and
also if i get a group of people together
and i just
cannot go today i'm gonna call them back
hey guys i'm super sorry i know i set
this up i can't make it today
i'll be there next time and they'll all
text me like ooh you're such a you're so
lame you want a loser you're an idiot
i'd be like i know i'm an idiot it's
cool
shake it off i'll be there next time and
if they're your if they're your gang
they'll be there next time and they'll
make fun of you hey remember the last
time you didn't show up
yeah that was super lame i just didn't
have it man and then we're gonna go
again and then we're gonna go watch the
fights we're gonna go watch the movie
we're gonna go
sing the songs or whatever it is we're
gonna do but
here's the thing it's not gonna be
something you can just waltz and sprint
back into
especially brother you're coming off
some heartbreak right
yeah the last big relationship you had
hurt you so your brain's got a vested
interest in keeping you away from other
people because they hurt
and your body has a vested interest in
you getting around people because that's
the only way to be well
okay does that make sense no it does it
makes perfect sense i just
it's like you said putting it back into
practice and
hey being an introvert dude is awesome
it's annoying too sometimes i wish i
could go out and be like hey everybody
woohoo
sometimes i just don't have it and so i
go and i hang out and i have a few
deep conversations in the corner i go
for an hour and then i leave
but there's something about that ritual
that practice that showing up and that's
showing up and that showing up and then
sometimes i go men and the wheels come
off and we
laugh and i'm loud and i'm silly and
ridiculous
and they're loud and they're like dude
you are an idiot and we all have a good
time
and then we get up and do it again the
next time but it's a practice
and i want to encourage you to when you
have those moments like
hey all the guys all the girls
everybody's getting together i think i'm
going to go sit with my dog
it sounds like you're telling me you
want to be out with your buddies
but you have that pool to go be with
your dog go be with your buddies even
when it's uncomfortable
be the first guy to say this is super
weird i'd rather be hanging out with my
pet but i knew i should come
be that guy right yeah but go first
okay go first if nothing else go first
and have your friends over to your place
tell everybody bring whatever weird
leftover gizmo they've gotten their
meal they've got in their uh kitchen
bring them over dude
and start small okay that sounds
feasible hey it's super is and it's
gonna be weird
and be the first guy to be like well i
was awkward
and appoint somebody next time we're
hanging out at your house because i just
screwed this up
and listen man you're still good you're
still alex from from
from los angeles california right
yeah you're still gonna be good
definitely you're still worth hanging
out you're still with having a community
so will you will you commit to america
and by america i mean like 18 listeners
will you admit to america or commit that
you're going to get a gang you're going
to get together with some friends this
weekend
yes i will you that's awesome alex good
for you brother
thank you so much for the call everybody
is going to be feeling weird in this
deal i saw
uh the the ufc's uh the the the ufc
that's going to florida that's the first
sporting event back it is
every i get sold out in eight seconds
like whatever it is
like fastest sellout in history whatever
there's gonna be those people i am
sprinting back as fast as i can
i'm throwing my mask in the air like a
like a like a diet coke commercial and
i'm just gonna be running in slow-mo to
the the next thing
and there's going to be those who are
like i'm going out and they open the
front door and they're like
nope and they're shutting the door back
everybody's going to be graceful with
one another there is no right or wrong
way to do this other than to remember
you gotta have community however weird
and wonky that looks for you
and you gotta practice that community
because we don't know what we're doing
right now
we're gonna stumble and trip and fall
and screw up and be idiots and be
silly and say the wrong things and we're
gonna have to forgive and be graceful
and then go again and go again and go
again and alex
you're a brave bold man for giving me a
shout i appreciate it go get em
go get em go get em all right so as we
wrap up today's show
dude fitzgerald in houston
back in the day they had this awesome
show it's called you ain't punk and all
the cool local houston punk bands will
get together
and play songs a whole set from another
like famous punk band this is the first
time i heard this and i remember the
song then i got hooked on them
this is from their 1985 album the
descendants
the album is called i don't want to grow
up it's one of the greatest punk bands
ever
they're so good man their key changes
are
their time scenes they're just good man
they're a lot of fun off the i don't
want to grow up
album it's a great romantic love song
it's an awkward love song just like
deloney would have been in middle school
and it goes like this it's called silly
girl started on a summer sunday pink
dress on a setting sun you were going to
grandma's house i was too scared to come
silly girl i'm begging you tell me all
the things i want to hear
silly girl i'm in love with you and i
had to run to get you you always move so
fast with your cute little smile and a
silly laugh
god gave me love at last and they said
just stay away and now i wish i had
i'm so in love with you my silly girl
and they made me go away sometimes life
doesn't
isn't fair but i'll be back someday i
hope you'll still be there and when
you're
just a silly boy like me you're always
so scared and now i'm just out of luck
and i wonder if you ever cared
oh silly girl i'm begging you don't stop
being nice to me
oh silly girl this is a song i would
have written
because i was the worst date ever this
has been the dr john de luna show